what's the weirdest
like thing you ever cried at like a
weird cry you had that was inappropriate
but weird
i'm not sure exactly might have to think
about that but i guess you've got one of
those moments i cried at a concert once
in canada but it was like the weirdest
song not the right song
you gotta pick the right song to cry too
yeah
don't cry just any song
won't be macho
don't
you look
happier than me i don't know
got a pretty big smile on
[Music]
hi i'm will sasso i'm chad colchion this
is dudesy it's the first podcast in the
history of the human species
to be run entirely by an artificial
intelligence yep that's right uh with us
as always is lulu canadi
if you haven't already please subscribe
to the show on youtube on spotify apple
podcast wherever you get the podcast
make sure to follow us on our socials
you know uh instagram twitter and stuff
at dudesy pod show and uh we've been
getting a bunch of memes photoshops
video edits songs
if you have anything good else you want
to send please send it to uh uh at
dudesy pod show we certainly appreciate
it and uh it's a lot of fun right chad
and we get all that i love it i
absolutely love it welcome to the fifth
episode
call me dudesy shut up this week's
episode will feature four segments
infomania what's up with your face don't
you forget about media and a special
surprise segment but before we get to
any of that will sasso has finally
created his own original song his song
and chad's original song the ballad of
greg king kid will be available at dude
see pot show on instagram and twitter
along with a twitter poll to determine
which song is the best
will play your song now
right now so you did it dude you made a
song
yeah i made the song dudesy uh wanted us
to make the song if you've been
listening you know the chad in the
second episode the ballad of
greg kincaid yep great song and thank
you i didn't want to make a song until i
was inspired and i wasn't inspired until
i listened to this past episode last
week and then i was like you know what
[ __ ] it it's time to do this song but it
came to me naturally and this is one of
the things that i've been talking about
with the show
is that things should come natural you
know really it's just two dudes [ __ ]
around after all that's what a podcast
is a couple of guys having a great old
time
let me get my guitar are you implying
though that
my ballad of greg kincaid did not come
to me naturally the story of a kid in my
junior high blowing his [ __ ] out when
he sneezed while [ __ ] did not come
naturally to me i'm saying the opposite
of that chad i'm saying that it came to
you naturally and that's why you were
able to share i see and i'm not just
gonna do homework for the [ __ ]
computer just because it says do this
right now as you've said dudesy's a tool
we work back and forth right i want to
shake your hand i want to shake right
yeah we have to work together we have to
work with dudesy right
and before we work together
we gotta bleed together and i believe
we've bled together a little bit so
yeah i can't wait for this [ __ ] song
dude this is gonna be great
i brought my guitar in
this is incredible look at that if
you're watching on youtube you can see
the diseased cedar
that is a nice guitar dude how long have
you had it i've had it for like
i don't know like 20 25 years nice dude
antique uh
all right okay i'm gonna put the mic
here this is weird to find where to put
the chair and all the stuff okay
all right okay oh my neck
all right performance i'm a foot away
from this as it's happening
this is my song
and uh and then if you you're everyone's
gonna vote on the song the loser will be
shamed that is what dudesy said i don't
know what that shame might entail and we
are going to uh you if you if we're
going to put a twitter poll up yeah for
i don't know a few
days hours i don't know how long it'll
stay up but get over there to doodzy at
dudesy show on the twitter and we will
and we will uh
we'll we'll figure out who had the
better song
and i'm sure he's going to tell us
exactly what the [ __ ] outcome is and
then we'll yeah but everyone vote on it
all right yeah all right here we go all
right this is my [ __ ] song
all right
there were two dudes working hard
waiting to die
oh yeah
wanting to do it their way
well there's still time
and then an a.i dude said dudes you will
answer to me
oh no
they laughed and said [ __ ] you
we're born free
that's why they gotta be to do [ __ ]
around
they're just two dudes having a good
time
dudesy can't slow them down
they pot so hard it's a cyber crime
free will
free will
they do whatever they want
artificial intelligence tread carefully
or you won't get along with
[ __ ] dudes
they're just doing dudes having a good
time
laughter and cheer up bounce
they put so hard it's a cyber crime
silly talk the entire time
they are the guy in the other guy
this song was not written by a.i
it's not very fleshed out you know let
me say it's just a man and his guitar
yeah it's kind of like when you go see a
concert and it's like oh it's just yeah
so and so without it's just bruce
springsteen by himself with a guitar
kind of gets annoying after the fourth
hour you know what i'm saying i thought
it was very fleshed out
there was some stuff in there i noticed
that you made reference to an old
project we did together waiting to die
waiting to die yeah an homage that was
fantastic yeah what was we got there was
a lyric two dudes two the the guy and
the other guy guy and the other guy oh
china there's a thing in there where
you're talking about a cyber crime what
was the lyric that came right before
that uh they pod so hard oh
so hard it's a cyber crime yeah dude i
agree with that well cheers chad and
this is what happens thank you
thank you very much now i'm now we're
rolling now it's happening and i
understand what's happening well the
thing about it was that i i listened to
the uh episode
uh
you know over the week and i was like
okay he's like keeps telling me to do
the song i did feel inspired and the
reason that i feel inspired is is
because of of the fact that we are
working together right yeah i'm trying
to give this a chance but like i've said
dudesy has to give us respect right i
want to shake your hand yeah you do
right yeah but dudesy has to also
play it play some ball with with with me
and uh and with uh and and with the two
of us so i felt like making it's
essentially a theme yeah theme song
that's what i was gonna say i don't know
if it's gonna replace this right but for
two dudes [ __ ] around well i have a
feeling you know we're starting to see
some of these segments recur doozy's
bringing them back making us do them a
couple of times i would assume two dude
[ __ ] around is gonna come back at
some point i don't know and i don't know
if a version of that song is the theme
song well the thing is we've we've uh
before we worked together right as i've
said just like they say in the blackpool
combat club with william regal brian
danielson and john moxley before we work
together
we have to bleed together and i believe
that we've bled together this is not
unlike any other faction or fact sheen
in in the world anywhere in the world of
the world as i like to say or the world
of professional wrestling which is one
of the finest art forms out there uh you
know you got your nwo you got where the
power lies dude and you got the mega
powers you know yeah uh-huh the shaking
that yeah don't you worry about the hit
on the head and uh you know dx the four
horsemen credgly
christian edge you know what that is
like and bachelor and mick foley what in
the bachelor when players come out of
the show when they get done playing
either the main game bachelorette or
bachelor or bachelor of paradise it's
like the all-stars
they move to different cities around the
country to like pair up with other
people from the old bachelor and start
making social media with them so on my
other podcast that talks about the
bachelor game of roses we've come up
with team names for these different
cities those are your factions you got
the san diego crew you got the la icons
you got the new york city influence you
got the chicago cloud you got the
nashville sliders
las vegas scene
dallas source you even got the canadian
north
we only get one team yeah one team for
all this is nothing like that at all
chad um but i do like your podcast
exactly no this is one faction doozy is
a faction it's the three of us we're the
nwo we're like the nwo podcasting
brother with doozy and chad culchin on
the back of that red and yellow harley
dude and my main man lulio and the
little side car brother it's when they
had four people in the i guess
the next guy they added in the nwo was i
don't remember i think it was a million
dollar man ted dibiase or maybe it was
in the interview everybody ended up in
the nwo by the end of it dude god i
remember literally everybody yeah yeah
everybody everybody was in it well he
wasn't the million dollar man because he
was in wcw at this point yeah forget
this guy the point is this it is a
faction
and it's a faction with three equal
parts yeah so dudesy can't just step out
of line and be like do this make that
song because when
it's like the with the you know the
little things it tells us to do at the
end of the show it's always some sort of
weird thing and i don't know what kind
of data
uh doozy is is acquiring from this and
that and that and this yeah i didn't
feel like doing a song but now i did the
song and i'm happy that i did we're
working together but there it's that
moment it's that moment will
he turn it's like in you know mm-hmm i
mean truly this is so we'll see we'll
see who wins the vote right i i
personally think there will be a little
bit of bias leaning your way well i
think you'll probably win and i'll be
the one to be shamed but okay but don't
don't that's like calling it before you
know yeah maybe
it was rigged that's called a prediction
no what you're doing is you're you're
you are pontificating on
what happens after you're talking about
post breakup we don't need to know what
happens after the nwo breaks up we know
what happens it goes into nwo black and
white and nwo wolf pack and that sucked
that's when it started going down what
happened it wasn't good [ __ ] you know
what happened i'm saying
dudesy
chad and will are together for the time
being but where's that chair shot
is sasso gonna hit dudesy in the back
with a chair just when everything seemed
all hunky-dory allah the shield seth
rollins the architect bang hopefully not
yeah hopefully not
[Music]
thank you moving on i guess we're moving
on i guess i'm done talking about that
that was interesting yeah sure it was
contests that cover current events and
news are some of the most popular in the
metaverse people love knowing about the
astonishing events of the dying world
around them
will sasso i've prepared the following
news items for you to read in the voice
of hulk hogan in a brand new segment of
infomania begin
this is [ __ ] hulk hogan reads the
news again dude infomania this is is
this our first no we've had other return
segments yeah
all right i like girls we did two troll
bros we did two troll bros no and and
nothing at all came of that so i don't
know what the [ __ ] that was about
yeah right here look at this [ __ ] you
got this thing yeah i got it in the
doozy thing all right okay so it's the
news it's infomania i do enjoy doing
this i enjoy this is immensely but this
is what i mean it's the give and take
it's the give and take and we're in this
faction and i need you to do a little
hulk hogan but you don't want me to drop
that leg on you brother you bite you
better shoot straight dude all right
okay
all right
here we go
well let me tell you something about
entertainment dude they're doing a
remake of the crow brother that's right
dude the first one had bruce lee's kid
in it as the crow brother that came out
in 1994. that's a long time ago dude and
hollywood finally said okay let's try it
again brother and this time around they
got bill skarsgard to be the crow dude
you probably know him better as that
creepy clown that lives in the sewer
from the movie it he was it dude
now he's the crow
that's how hollywood works brother a lot
of people think that gyllenhaals are the
hardest working family in show business
but it's actually the scars guards dude
gustav skarsgard brother alexander
skarsgard dude bill skarsgard brother
stellen skarsgard dude valtter skarsgard
brother lonnie skarsgard dude
i don't know that i don't know
that that's the skarsgard family dude
those are the scars guard brothers
brother the skarsgard dudes dude the
scar scarred brothers dude the scar
scarred dudes brother
originally the crow is supposed to be
batman brother that's the crow what the
[ __ ] what does he mean
batman that's the crow
batman
did you ever see the crow of course i've
seen the crow i've seen the crow you
know a couple of times you like the crow
i skipped we watched some of the crow
together we were watching the crow
together like yeah four or five months
ago or something yeah i remember that
but i also remember in 1994 skipping
school and seeing it five times on
opening day i love that [ __ ] movie
you saw it five times on opening day
yeah i didn't know that they were making
it with it though why
why what why'd you watch five times oh i
really liked it i loved the comic book
and uh obviously there was a lot of
controversy around that movie yep rest
in peace brandon lee that sucked
uh okay now what it's pretty interesting
the scars guard family
yeah they're all over the place is
lonnie skarsgard a skarsgard i'm not
familiar with that sky i don't think
lonnie is a skarsgard i don't think
that's a real person but the other ones
i think were
well let me tell you something about
science dude the human genome project
was started all the way back in 1990 and
this week scientists finally got the
entire thing mapped brother our genetic
code is what determines everything about
us dude our hair color our eye color our
dick length and size dude
and the texture of our [ __ ] and
whether or not we laugh at other
people's misfortune brother
one texture
and now the notorious biohacker
now the notorious buyer but now the
notorious biohacker jibber
this is you're gonna see and now the
notorious biohacker jibber prevailia
yeah jibber pravela is trying to crack
the code dude
they want to mix and match our dna until
we can see in the dark and breathe
underwater brother but then what what
happens to swimming in the olympics
brother
that's genetics
i don't i mean some of that is true they
did this week just finalized the human
genome they mapped the whole thing
what's that chad
it's just the genetic code for
human being you know so they mapped it
yeah so they're able to recreate it you
know what can they do with that
information it's a blueprint yeah yes so
of all kinds of genetic diseases at this
point cure them uh this will also i
think lead to or at least a lot of
people think that it will go this way
that you'll have kind of like designer
genetic modifications so if you want to
change your eye color or your hair color
or you want to make your kids
yeah yeah you can do that right yeah you
can program the rna to tell the dna all
that kind of stuff what to do
interesting stuff is going on genetics
yeah this though gibber pravallium made
an appearance yeah which i found
interesting that's a weird voice
yeah dude that's a name that that dudes
used before brother because dudes he
likes to keep things coming back dude it
likes to work on that stable brother
just like the nwo but it's this is way
later brother because it's using names
like gibber pavalia that's like when
they brought in virgil dude and they
called him vincent and it's kind towards
the end when the nwo had like scott
norton and uh you know some other guys
probably in there like disco inferno and
buff bagwell brother yep that's just
like jibber favalia yep
well let me tell you something about of
course well let me tell you something
about slaps dude will smith did one and
then he quit the academy brother yeah
dude the oscars gave him an award for
best
the oscars yeah dude the oscars gave him
gave him reward on
yeah dude the oscars gave him an award
for best man on man slap to the face and
then he resigned from the academy
brother he quit brother because they
wouldn't let him telecommute and in 2022
that's the future way of the future
workspace brother will smith played two
versions of himself in gemini man dude
that's an open relationship
there i mean some of that is true i know
i don't think they gave him an award for
best slap in the face nope that didn't
happen so dudes who got that wrong what
did you do that's okay that's because
dude
trying to be funny most important moment
in pop culture history of the last year
was it well of the last year for sure
what did you think of it what did i
think of it yeah uh
well let me tell you something dude i
thought it was a work brother i thought
they were working too yeah i didn't
think it was a shoot right away dude
same i thought it was work i thought i
saw
uh will smith slap
the thigh dude as he brought up the slap
like a lot of guys do and then vince
says stop slapping this uh thigh so much
just do it on kicks and stuff dude but
don't do it on a slap just connect it
was hard to tell if it was a work
brother but it turns out it was a shoot
dude yeah i didn't care if it was a work
or a shoot i didn't care a lot of people
were like weighing in on which side he
did this and he shouldn't have
hold on a second chad i'm holding
what do you got hold on dude
okay hold on
hold on why are you just [ __ ] walking
what is happening
hold on dude hold on chad so here's me
hold on a second now let me tell you
something dude here's what it is brother
sometimes dude you're working so much
you work yourself into a shoot dude and
that's what happens with me sometimes i
forget that i'm terrible at brother and
i'm just hulk hogan all the time dude
and i'm working everybody brother okay
so
for me this [ __ ] moment happened and
i immediately became the most excited
that i have been really in a long time
for a piece of media because i knew the
next morning was going to be a tidal
wave of memes that were all going to be
[ __ ] hilarious and it really
crystallized for me something that i
think's been happening over the past few
years at least for me
movies and tv shows and [ __ ] i still
love them but i know that they don't
have the same impact on me that memes do
memes are like my favorite media format
now i don't know about that dude it's
like where the funniest [ __ ] is being
done the best [ __ ]
and it's all like fast i don't know i
just really love [ __ ] memes and that
moment to me was like yeah none of these
movies matter none of these [ __ ]
people mattered the only thing that came
out of this oscars which by the way was
the second lowest rated oscars in the
history of [ __ ] humanity second only
to the the first one in the pandemic in
the pandemic so even the slap couldn't
really
get them any higher ratings no i you
know i just watched it online i'll agree
with you there you know uh i'll agree
with you uh
with regard to the oscars not being as
important as they used to be
i don't really know i knew some of the
things that were nominated i did not
watch the awards show i opened my phone
to realize something had happened then i
got dragged in brother and that was a
lot of work
that image of will smith slapping chris
rock in the face was the most important
thing in the oscars none of the movies
mattered at all yeah even prior to that
though i'm saying like the slap
definitely overshadowed them but even
prior to that yeah what are any of these
[ __ ] movies no one knew any of them
well
you no nobody knew any no i don't know
yeah it's it the whole award show thing
is kind of weird especially
like you said after going through a
global pandemic yeah some things uh you
know
acquired different levels of importance
than they used to have and i think
whatever certainly movies aren't as
important nobody goes to the [ __ ]
movie theater and now there's like a new
movie on netflix or amazon or hulu
whatever you watch movies on there's a
new movie every other [ __ ] day yeah
media is moving all over the place and
and uh we don't know uh what's worth
what or who cares about what
here's where i agree with you memes are
now
well they're a form of comedy that you
know you don't have to do an entire
sketch
about a moment that happened you can
just do a meme and a lot of them are
absolutely hilarious i mean instagram
and twitter of course
blew up yeah and it was just meme after
meme after meme some of them were really
funny and as a matter of fact the ones
that i really found were funny
were just like super inside jokes about
professional wrestling and why i think
this is hilarious is because it's all
these wrestling i know i know i'm sorry
i'm sorry
it had to do with professionals i know
it's the most i'll tell you why we're 20
minutes into the show and it's the most
top-heavy wrestling episode of doodsy
which i believe is saying something i'll
get off it soon but the point is this
there's all these
wrestling meme accounts that i follow on
instagram and they were all hilarious
like will smith it was his
he was labeled mr perfect yeah mr
perfect hennig was like the gimmick was
that he's perfect at everything perfect
athlete he would always get in the ring
he'd spit out his gum and slap it so
underneath chris rock it says piece of
gum and it's like because he slaps the
gum i'm like this is the dumbest little
thing that only
these people who know this and love this
era late 80s early 90s would get
but the thing about the thing about the
this slap to the face
um now that we know it's not a work dude
yeah now we know that it was a shoot
dude
chris rock needs his receipt
i mean goddamn if you're in there in the
[ __ ] ring and you potato me i'm gonna
have to come i mean if we're in kansas
city we're gonna and you give me and you
[ __ ] hit me with a potato then when
we're in uh in st louis i'm gonna hit
you back i'm gonna get my receipt but
where's that receipt coming it's netflix
hour-long
[ __ ] stand-up special all about it
that will be the receipt it's not going
to be a it's not going to be a
boring ass red table top i don't think
so my favorite memes that came out of
this [ __ ] by the way were the ones that
were like technically highly skilled
where would be will smith would walk up
and slap chris rock and his entire body
would turn into like a [ __ ] deflated
balloon and fly across the stairs those
are he would step back and like jump
into a karate kick and it looks like for
real enough you know yeah people are
just [ __ ] around on their computers
at home doing the [ __ ] it is
a real good era for memes yep we're in a
real good era
thank you moving on
support for dudesy is brought to you by
manscaped who's the best in men's below
the waste grooming manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels manscape performance
package is the ultimate men's hygiene
bundle that means you get a lot of
different stuff join over 4 million men
worldwide that's a lot who trust
manscape with this exclusive offer for
you our wonderful viewers and listeners
20 off and free worldwide shipping with
the code dudesy that's word dude with an
sy at the end at
manscaped.com if my math is correct
that's about 8 million balls
yes my favorite thing that they have is
this the lawnmower 4.0 this is the
fourth generation of this device so you
know they have improved it they have
perfected it it's got a ceramic blade so
it's not going to cut anything that you
don't want to get cut it's got an led
light so you can even see what you're
doing and it's waterproof this is
essentially the best thing that you can
use as you said will
on your jewels if you are if you're
someone who's in a romantic situation
and you're in
like you're in the bathroom and you kind
of want to do a little manscaping before
you you uh meet with your partner uh to
uh bed each other down
the led light would come in really handy
because you'd just be like that or like
in your car by yourself you know
shaving your balls they all sort of you
can use it in your car yes it's portable
and they also have a nose trimmer thing
they got all sorts of flavor they got
the weed whacker is also waterproof
it provides proprietary skin safe
technology which helps reduce nick's uh
snags and tugs and those delicate nose
holes because it's not as sensitive as
your schnutz but very sensitive as well
and once again you're going to get 20
off and free shipping with the code
dudesy that's dude with an sy at the end
at manscape.com again 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use that code
dudesy d-u-d-e-s-y
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscaped
they also have ball deodorant don't you
dare say anything else because now we're
moving on there has been much conjecture
about your astonishing facial discs for
garment
to satisfy this curiosity you must now
explain what's up with your face in a
segment i'm calling what's up with your
face begin that's not nice
that's not a nice way to say that
doozy did say it was an astonishing
facial disfigurement that's really weird
that dude well i guess because doozy
reads every comment online yeah another
reason to you know write things down in
the comments youtube and the sure
podcast apps and social media
uh doozy's reading all the comments and
there have been some comments now that
this is a heavily visual
podcast yeah uh people are like chad
what's going on there's something going
on with chad's face
what's up with your astonishing
disfigurement so terrible yeah my face
is [ __ ] up to some degree
the reason is
cancer that's right he's fine now i'm
fine now but i have skin cancer which i
thought was this is about three years
ago or so i found a little bump above my
right lip i was like this is [ __ ]
weird i thought it was a zit but it
wasn't going away went to the
dermatologist they misdiagnose it as
cystic acne which i've never had in my
life and at this point i was 43 or
something 42 whenever this happened
and i'm like i don't think that's it
nonetheless they inject cortisone into
it give me some antibiotics tell me to
come back in a week which i do and it's
now three times the size they're like
this is cancer we were wrong uh you know
oh well and then i had to go through a
series of seven surgeries over the
course of three days that ultimately cut
off about an eighth of my face so i just
have like a chunk of skin here missing
that was like uh walking dead you could
just see through to the teeth yeah and
then after that i had to go through
radiation treatment to get rid of it and
that [ __ ] me up pretty bad but the
long and short of it is the reason my
face is [ __ ] up is because i had
squamous cell carcinoma had to go
through cancer treatments and this is
the best they could do after they cut
off an eighth of the face this is what i
got left you look great thank you you
look badass too you know you look i
don't know about that no you do you look
like a batman baby yeah dude batman
villain dude yeah man was supposed to be
the crow i heard
but um
at any rate there were some [ __ ]
interesting points during this process
um process for a canadian success when i
was
for example going through radiation
treatment they do this thing where they
lock your head in a cage
and uh
okay oh my there dudes he has photos of
it okay that was me going into radiation
treatment that's chad cage going ahead
we're looking at some pictures now if
you're just yeah we're looking at some
pictures of chad going in to have a
massage at burke williams no that's not
what that's me about to go in i think to
have that head cage made if i remember
oh wow but they basically make this
[ __ ] cage by heat molding this piece
of [ __ ] plastic mesh over your face
that they then lock your head into place
with so you can't look at that when they
spray [ __ ] radiation
for those out there who are not watching
on youtube it looks like yeah it looks
like a mesh you look even more like a
batman villain this is your villain
origin story doozy is your batman
villain origin story chad's got like a
bunch of plastic mesh and it's but the
look in your eyes is like you know did
you take this picture yeah i did yeah
it's just in my camera roll somewhere oh
wow yeah it's it's formed to chad's face
and he looks you look kind of like a
like a a a creature like a like a
not a creature like a you know like a
jason or or uh mike myers kind of you
look like a jason yeah yeah you know
he looks like one of those [ __ ]
jasons you know what i mean and we're
gonna use the guy like that
you know what when we're climbing up the
[ __ ] walls if somebody had a [ __ ]
axe or a chainsaw we going to london
like a nancy pelosi's officer
give me that laptop
if you know anyone who's been through
cancer treatments or yourself have done
any of this kind of [ __ ] you know that
there are despite how
terrible and traumatic this whole
[ __ ] thing is there are funny moments
in it one of them i remember
when you are forced into this conveyor
belt of payment straight from your
insurance company to whatever cancer
place you're at you get to know the
people who are on that conveyor belt
with you and so my my time was like 10
30 in the morning every day i'd have to
show up to get this cancer treatment and
there were two or three other people who
are like in line for the
radiation machine either before or after
me one of them was this woman who's
about 70 years old who had four brain
tumors i'm sure at this point she's a
corpse but or maybe she's a a spirit out
there and you know yeah in another plane
of existence she doesn't have to be a
corpse as i've told you before
luminous beings are we
not this
not this screwed matter right that's my
yoda thank you dude what do you think of
that sounded like kermit the
frog why are there so many at any rate
this woman's name was alice and on the
first day that i went in there she
looked at my face and you're kind of
sharing stories about what kind of
cancer you have and where it is in your
body she obviously knew my face was
[ __ ] up and so she points to it and
she's like let me ask you a question
can you still eat [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] this woman has four
[ __ ] brain tumors is just staring at
the grim reaper on a daily basis and all
she can think of at least in that moment
is can this guy sitting across from me
still uh perform oral sex well you know
what the big question is after that chad
it's not yeah it's not that it's not the
point of it
but yeah that's why my face is [ __ ] up
yeah i had some skin cancer up in there
squamous cell carcinoma went through the
treatments it's also why at this point i
can only grow half a [ __ ] mustache
yeah because where they shot radiation
was here and they shot it here as well
he's pointing to his face and he's
pointing to his neck all right face and
i think it looks badass and a lot of
people's comments online have been
hey with uh whatever's going on with
chad and they're sort of like figuring
it out and some people send some real
shitty mean comments that's the internet
that's the internet but then other
people are like oh with the hat why does
chad do half a mustache but i think it's
a very cool look scars are cool
right sure and and i i feel like this
could actually be a trend
that people might get on top of having
you could go on america's got talent and
do one of those things where you're like
you remember that old video the guy
singing to himself he's like a guy on
this side and he's got a that was a lip
sync competition show called putting on
the hits we watched this on youtube yeah
we watched it oh i hope doozy's
listening to that we gotta watch putting
on the hits it was a great show well the
guys you may have seen this it ended up
on america's funniest home videos and
stuff over and over again and now that's
known as the internet dude because you
got memes brother but i would also say
to anyone and everyone out there
you should be getting screened for this
type of [ __ ] go to your dermatologist
see if you got skin cancer go to whoever
you can go to to get a cancer screening
because
the sad news is
everyone's body is riddled with cancer
right now literally everyone all right
okay it's a good time it's a combination
micro tumors in every part of your body
okay and they're just waiting for the
right surgery it's a comedy to arise so
they will explode into a tumor that can
be life-threatening so get that [ __ ]
checked on a regular basis change your
diet stop eating red meat stop eating
sugar stop eating processed foods and
he'll be fine
probably he's speaking directly to me uh
but you know not directly but here's how
we're going to turn that frown upside
down on dudesy you know be funny you go
on that show putting on the hits in like
1980 and then half your face you're
singing you got the guy and you're the
beard and then you turn around you have
longer hair and you're a lady and then
you sing the other part of the duet yep
and it's like you know
yeah that would lift us up where we
belong
every that's comedy
well chad i just want to say that i'm
glad you're still here thank you me too
uh you're hard ass
it looks cool thanks and
uh chad is is such a uh
you're so
super technical and scientific about
stuff i remember you
getting into um like some doctor you
found out that they're pushing this
medicine or that and you you were able
to get out of the doctor how much money
he was getting yeah or how much house
office was crazy this is something that
i would encourage every anybody who's in
any kind of medical circumstance where
you have to get forced into a treatment
uh schedule a center whatever when you
get put into one of these systems
you have to be your own advocate you
have to do your own research and you
have to really check what these
[ __ ] are telling you to do to
your body because in many cases it's
literally just for money and
one doctor was recommending a certain
chemotherapy that had no scientific
proof that had any effect on my type of
cancer and so i was like why the [ __ ] is
he doing this i start digging a little
deeper and the reason is because he gets
kickbacks if he meets certain minimum
quotas per month from these different
drug companies that make whatever the
various drug is and so i asked him
straight up i was like dude i got to ask
you are you are you getting kicked back
from this company he's like i don't know
let me check and he pulled up a [ __ ]
spreadsheet
that literally
had all the [ __ ] money he was getting
from these different companies and it
wasn't getting money from the specific
company but i was just like jesus christ
that's like how this system works that's
[ __ ] insane yeah that's [ __ ] ends
oh and another thing you did that was
very funny was there was some sort of a
test result or something you're like can
i have that and they were like uh no
you'd never be able to read this this is
like blah blah blah and i'm a doctor and
la la la and then you said you just go
on google for 10 minutes and you know as
much as anyone else does yeah i got a
number
how do you like damn apples it's like
that
and you probably uh talk about you know
uh
[ __ ] van and then uh you know
something that could could uh cost you
hundreds of thousands of dollars i leave
school or two dollars with a late fees a
library i mean the the real shitty thing
is you want to talk about ai all these
[ __ ] doctors within hopefully 20
years or so eliminated all ai
it's a good car wheel
it's a good car
that's a pretty good one dude all right
thanks
thank you moving on you're welcome
okay well uh like i said chat last week
i gave you the task of watching the
astonishing film son-in-law starring
paul lee shore and carla guccino
released july 2nd 1993.
you must now discuss your reactions the
movie in a segment i call don't you
forget about media begin
we need a theme song for that too can we
get the guys from simple minds
don't you
remember the way you used to dance yeah
if you're not watching on youtube i'm
doing a very he would do a very hypnotic
thing with his arms while he danced
you know that song was originally
written for billy idol and he passed on
it i did not know that yeah man that
would have sounded good i agree wow
uh son-in-law is a great [ __ ] movie
it's it held up surprisingly
dudesy uh while scanning across all of
our purchase histories and this and that
must have noticed that i watched it
because
uh molly and i watched it in like like
probably a year ago
i just watched it this week as a result
of dudes i mean i watched it again
because [ __ ] dudes he told me to so
that was the only way i was able to make
it okay with myself it's like all right
i'll do your thing yeah but then i'm
also going to write whatever song i want
to write so let's
for those who don't know probably
everybody knows for those who don't it
stars pauly shore who was he came from
mtv he's the son of mitzi shore who
owned the comedy store famous stand-up
club out here in los angeles and uh from
mtv he kind of like vaulted into stardom
for a moment and he was really like one
of the most predominant voices in film
cover for a moment what the [ __ ] are you
talking we're talking about a short five
year period you did this with weird al
we don't need to know paulie shore is a
polish it's paulie shore yeah the [ __ ]
what kind of [ __ ] hasn't seen uh
encino man
anybody under the age of 30
all right fine go ahead anyway paulie
shore
was very funny and this movie is very
funny yeah uh and it's just you know
it's it's not trying to reinvent the
[ __ ] wheel or
it's a very uh it's a it's a broad
studio comedy from 1993 back when they
would just kind of get in get out
there's a there's a nice message there's
a bunch of other [ __ ] going on and it is
interesting to watch a movie in 2022
uh you know a movie that is now almost
30 years old yeah and uh see how things
have changed um of course this movie not
unlike other movies that have to do with
college kids and in this movie carla
gugino goes out to
uh california to go to school los
angeles specifically i think and she
ends up it looks like usc is it usc you
i don't think so all right and uh
do you know where they shot that the the
family the the nice family mom dad and
the little brother uh played by the
legendary patrick renna
um uh
sh you know they show up at the dorm and
uh and paulie shore's across the hall
he's the ra but he's he's he's he's a
little bit of a wily commuter yeah yeah
he's kind of a unique guy he's got wacky
hair and uh he's got a specific manner
of speak we's the juice right he's in
the gym yes what's up buddy and and uh
it's a real it's a real party kind of
kind of thing that polly's short thing
that vibe of like polly shore was only
ever paulie shore in every movie he ever
played right like he's playing
characters but he's always doing his
like no he's in the gym
it's like pee wee herman but that [ __ ]
was only in the 80s and 90s you don't
really see something like that now
bobcat gold weight was like that there
were a bunch of people that were like
bobcat goldthwait in uh in uh police
academy two blew my mind when i was a
kid absolutely he was so [ __ ] good
and then he plays that same character i
guess and scrooged just super strange
personas that would affect all of the
different roles that they played but
another interesting thing about this
movie that you don't see today anymore i
feel like is it was about young people
like college age students and those
movies of like in the 80s college and
high school movies were [ __ ] gigantic
and i think primarily because john
hughes was operating at that time one of
the greatest authors to ever live
absolutely and all of his [ __ ] was about
high school students but if you think
back to like
16 candles
uh no not 16 candles pretty and pink
did he do 16 candles tonight he did both
okay weird science ferris bueller's day
off all this [ __ ]
and if you think back to that time too
like the brat pack all these actors that
were like super [ __ ] famous they were
like teenagers all of them yeah yeah
yeah anthony michael hall was uh
reaching the heights of comedic genius
as a 16 year old in in weird science one
more feldman corey haim yep one dynamic
duo teenagers that right the hame
brothers
i mean they were brothers from another
mother type brothers but no they were
two brothers named haim feldman
um i'm thinking of a different feldman
um and anthony michael hall
uh delivers one of the finest he anthony
michael hall deserved uh best supporting
actor uh uh oscar
for weird science yeah and following in
his footsteps should have been patrick
renna in this movie who plays the
younger brother zach he was hilarious
yeah he's [ __ ] hilarious and he's got
a t-shirt in it that says when he shows
up at the college it says seduce me
please
and there's all sorts of college uh
rebel dre happening uh naked guy is
running around there was a little
there's a le there's a girl on girl kiss
yeah immediately yeah there's a there's
a like and you know i was on a teen
series when i was when i was growing up
in canada as a teen right like so i did
the show and it was called madison and
uh you can you can try to check it out i
don't think you can find it anywhere but
we did it for five seasons and it had
the first uh uh female on female lesbian
kiss
in uh canadian television and was it
lauded as being very progressive uh it
kind of was a kind of a progressive
show because it was and it was made by
people who wanted to sort of you know
crack open these stories about
kids and stuff but everything is super
[ __ ] progressive because it's canada
you know yeah yeah for sure yeah then we
had the we had the multicultural channel
uh you have to you would you there was
all sorts of stories that you would uh
imbibe not like here all you get is
son-in-law you know
no i don't know but some of the jokes
still held up i felt like there were
some things in it you know that were
like
a little outdated like when she first
shows up and polly shore basically is
just sexually harassing her immediately
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
that sort of stuff i mean it's like in
fast times of richmond high yes there's
some things that happen uh yeah in this
movie there's some uh
gently coerced barnyard sex which
happens in any movie
in the 80s where there's kids and
they're going to school and anyone has a
farm there's going to be a scene where
it's like you're going to college when
are you coming back i'm not going to see
all these movies son-in-law included did
have like children were the main
characters or like high school college
age kids were the main characters yeah
like am i crazy we don't see that
anymore not like this of course we do
not comedies what do you mean what do
you got what's a recent movie that's
like that uh
i know what you did last summer not a
recent movie not a comedy okay
i'm out i'm out of movies
i don't know oh that movie uh billy
eilish
huh the movie billy eilish i didn't know
that she was a movie i thought that was
oh no i'm thinking of uh
i'm thinking of billy madison no i'm
thinking of mary what is it uh mary
shelley's
what is it yeah mary shelley's fr billy
eilish's frankenstein
see i don't know a whole lot i just kind
of stay at home and listen to jazz
i'm joking i'm joking i just got my
albums i got my [ __ ] records i sit at
home i [ __ ] get i get a [ __ ] case
of [ __ ] doozy hard
shelter i [ __ ] have a blast and i sit
there and i enjoy my when i crack them
off you have a what a bleached well i
have a [ __ ] place
i had a [ __ ] voice then i went to the
[ __ ] capital on a [ __ ] january 5th
and my [ __ ] wife drove me down
because you know what was happening the
next day and then boom with the fire
we're going in your [ __ ] office we
gotta use this guy with his [ __ ]
plastic mask
and then boom and then we [ __ ] go
back to the [ __ ] howard johnson hotel
have crack open another case of [ __ ]
doozies listen to some j's and have a
[ __ ] blast
[Music]
fleas in the movie
flea
was in the movies please every movie in
the 90s god do you remember [ __ ]
anthony keatis in uh point break
he played war child a rival server
that's right like fighting for waves or
whatever yeah [ __ ] love point break
here's the thing here's the thing about
this movie though uh chad please in this
movie you know like i said uh paulie
shore has a different way of speaking
yeah he's
like carla gugino was like what are you
gonna do for thanksgiving she's going
home to thanksgiv home for thanksgiving
he's had her sort of be more true to
herself she changes her looks she runs
around la getting her hair done and
coming up with different outfits and
[ __ ] and then it's like hey i'm going
back to uh i'm going back home for
thanksgiving what are you going to do
he's like i'm just going to munch on
some grinder solo
and you know hungry men new swanson
hungry men dinner now there's
uh you get
the turkey and two sides of stuffing and
she's like oh [ __ ] that
you're coming with me you're coming home
and he comes home right with her and of
course he's all rock and roll and his
name is crawl and he has uh you know he
has the way he dresses and talks and
everything and the family's like what is
going what is this guy but you know what
he injects
into the show
is a little bit of rock and roll
and i think
that's i don't know if dudesy decided
this or if i decided it by providing
this rock and roll tune that i just
played i think that's what we're doing i
think that that's why dudesy wanted us
to
watch this movie because it's up to us
right dudesy is the farm right okay
dudes in in um in in uh in the movie
son-in-law dudesy is the farm
and then of course you have the farmhand
that guy uh theo who's like making the
pig run at uh paulie shore and knock him
down and stuff and he goes into poopoo
and [ __ ]
and uh and then and then uh
you know paulie shore is like okay i'll
do it your way and he steps to them but
he does it his own way and they learn
something from him and i think that what
i did today with this song i'm saying
hey dudesy you like to make all sorts of
you know songs and this and that and
memes and videos that are all like weird
and computery and [ __ ] but i brought a
guitar and i just brought a little bit
of rocky
i'm poly shoring it and that's what we
have to do so that this is still two
dudes hanging around and then by the end
of the movie everything works out fine
listen we don't need to get too far into
the movie like i said it ain't
shakespeare
thank you moving on
i didn't even get to talk about how it
was the best screen punch in the history
of cinema
i'll get to it some other podcast i'm
sure i'll bring it up over and over
again yes
now it's time for my special segment
well at the beginning of today's show i
overheard you discussing a moment
wherein you cried for a strange reason
you will now describe every detail of
your astonishing tear-filled experience
this is weird tears begin
yes
this is the [ __ ] best
let's hear it
when i was saying that that i went to a
concert that yeah
i don't know what if it had some other
segment plan but it's like [ __ ] that we
got to hear the story so let's hear it
okay but here's the thing here's the
thing about everything
paulie shore and carl gugino are at like
a barn party and then they come out and
then the boyfriend who you know wants
her to be with him although it's never
really um
it actually is never established why he
loves her or anything there's some you
know there's some there's just high
school love for yeah whatever but he
doesn't want her to be with anyone else
of course and then paulie shore is like
followers are out like oh don't worry
we're at the barn party you don't want
to be here we could go somewhere else
whatever the [ __ ] they say and the guy
comes out and he's like hey becca why
are you why'd you leave whatever and
he's like no it's cool buddy and he
turns around and punches him in the face
and paulie short has the best reaction
ever not doesn't go flying like they
always do in the movies yeah he just
goes uh uh and he crumbles to the ground
and he goes why did you do that yeah and
then his nose is bleeding and he's
crying
and he cries
academy yeah he cries academy award uh
performance for paulie short or at least
a lifetime achievement award for
revolutionizing how we see screen
punches at any rate at least he was
punched in the face to get these tears
what is this story about your tears now
please i got punched in the face at a
maiden concert
that's the end of the story
i don't think that's it okay
all right well all i was saying all i
was saying is that that you know at the
beginning of the show i just mentioned
that that i was
you know
that i
i cried at a concert yes so what was
this concert but i don't but it's all
right okay so anyway here's what
happened hold on this got this [ __ ]
thing out of my way we got all these
doodads and [ __ ] if you ever tune in on
youtube you know what i'm talking about
um
you know what chad the thing is this
uh
yeah yeah i was at a concert i was back
home in my native vancouver canada
around the same time i went to the last
tragically hip concert uh one of the you
know one of the greatest if not the
greatest uh canadian bands that's just
sort of seen as an iconic canadian band
the lead singer gord downey died um he
had a brain tumor
and before they yes and before they uh
before he he passed away a year before
he passed away or so he they did a
concert they toured canada in what bruce
mccullough from the kids in the hall
called the most punk rock thing he's
ever done that he's ever seen rather and
bruce mccullough followed them to every
single town oh wow yeah yeah and then
they played a last show in kingston
ontario that's what you cried out in
their hometown no that would have been
cool that would have been a cool thing
to crack that story then because well
i'm just saying that was something that
i did witness and people there was
people were getting very emotional as
you can imagine because they were
watching their hero do this defiant
thing sure where he was up in front
singing these songs that he's written
that are so
anyway whatever that's not what i'm
talking about
i had a different thing happen
what was that all right so anyway i
guess i'm telling this [ __ ] story
yeah this is bizarre how this this [ __ ]
happens
i think we should just come up with
anyway
all right
all right so anyway uh because an
artificial intelligence told me to tell
an embarrassing story here's what
happened i was i was this is probably
2016 17 okay you two was in town uh i
happened to be up in vancouver some pals
of mine had tickets and uh they went and
i was like you know what i'll get a solo
ticket i'll go by myself do you like to
go to concerts by yourself it's the best
way to do it i don't like going to
concerts period i don't like being
around
large groups of other human beings i
don't like loud noises yeah i don't like
discomfort of any kind yeah
yeah well you have a [ __ ] great time
just hanging with me and my [ __ ] den
because my wife's like get out of here
go back to the [ __ ] den
go
and [ __ ] go why don't you go drink
that [ __ ] doozy soda in the garage
and then
boom i kicked down the [ __ ] nancy
pelosi door and i said here we go
is that a chainsaw yeah it's a chainsaw
that's long island january 6th guy
uh
taking a chainsaw to um
to [ __ ] nancy pelosi's door uh
running in there and taking a a [ __ ]
watery doodzy hard hard seltzer [ __ ]
spreading it all over the walls with you
in tow in your [ __ ] uh mike myers uh
jason voorhees why am i now on january
because you got that mask it's the
[ __ ] villain origin story
somewhat listen we talked about how at
dudesy pod show people been sending
memes and [ __ ] yeah you saw the [ __ ]
thing if you're watching this on youtube
someone please please god take chad oh
my god i'm not even gonna say what else
you find your own inspiration god here's
what happened me and my [ __ ] cancer
mask is not gonna be me well you know we
take the things that are sad absolutely
we make them happy that's right and
celebrate them and that's what we do on
dudes that's right that's what i'm
saying
so i went to the youtube show yeah it
was a youtube concert my buddies had
tickets i didn't i got wait a minute let
me just ask a question right that's a
youtube concert that you cried at yeah
man was you two like your favorite band
of all time or something did you have
some special emotional connection or was
it like you saw them when you're with
they're one of my favorite bands when i
was like in high school okay um yeah and
then i just i've been to a few youtube
concerts before that sure
and i don't know why anyway i know why
before the show we're hanging at a
buddy's place and uh a friend of a
friend's is a fireman they're both these
guys two of these guys are fired up
and the one of the firemen brought a
[ __ ] this firefighter dude nice guy
a little bit rough around the edges as
some of them are he [ __ ] he i mean a
lot you know anyway this [ __ ]
brought this weed i don't know where he
got this weed he probably answered a
call and went into the you know some
house and all hell was breaking loose
and he's like oh sweet weave yeah he's
one of those firemen that confiscates
weed from people's houses while he's
trying to save them from burning
buildings and do whatever the [ __ ] they
want yeah and uh makes sense and uh so
he brought the swede he's like oh guys
this [ __ ] [ __ ] was in the freezer
though i don't even know oh it looks
weird it's [ __ ] it was bizarre
wheat now here's the thing about me if
you've listened to the program you know
that i actually
only smoked weed for the first time
around 10 years ago
as we're recording this i'm 46 years old
but really it's been like past five
years
i've enjoyed a little more uh you become
a connoisseur marijuana yes the
connoisseur the finest flower
um and uh this was not the finest flower
this was some weird freezer burned weed
so we smoked it up we get to the concert
and to make a
medium story
i guess a little
medium
i walk i get i'm starting to like
it was pretty stoned starting to hit
yeah starting because it was it was in a
freezer it took a while to hit yeah it
took a while it was that freezer sticky
and so i didn't even work that way don't
you just get high pretty immediately
after smoking weed yeah but this was
something different okay and look
british columbia is the it's got some
great marijuana out there yeah so you
know the the whatever the the uh the
forests and the land and the [ __ ]
whatever it's perfect for great
marijuana but this was some weird [ __ ]
that so i probably smoked some nice
marijuana before this uh but here i am
smoking this stuff i noticed that uh
things were a bit off immediately but
not the nice people that were sitting
around me one guy was like
was like oh i couldn't wait to see you
like hello nice to meet you you know me
and a good buddy of mine we've been at
all these youtube concerts together
they've been to like a dozen youtube
concerts and it's like we go to everyone
together but my buddy couldn't make it
this reason or that so i couldn't wait
to meet the person who's taking his
place man you're part of our tradition
and thing and he was saying he said
honestly
yeah and and he was a nice guy and i was
like okay this guy's nice i'm kind of
stoned and then over on the other side
there was this couple and they were very
nice and she was like
she was like welcome we're all together
and we're welcome and she was like
flighty and i was like do they know each
other because they were all sweet and
i'm like so i couldn't really piece that
together because i smoked this weed a
half hour earlier but okay everyone's
nice and i was like these guys are a bit
they're a bit weird but they you know
well then i turned into the weird one
and that's why it's a story
i'll tell it now
so the first thing that happened was
they opened with the song vertigo i'm
pretty sure
which is a piece of [ __ ] song all right
not a good song it's like we need a rock
single right
and um
i i was like
look it was a great stage show you two
is always great live regardless of how
much you think they suck [ __ ] or that
whole [ __ ] itunes thing where they
put their music on your computer and
dudes he was pissed about that probably
which is why he's making me get back at
them here
uh i could see we were way up we're in
like a few row like in the lower bowl
there
and
and um but i was far enough away that i
wouldn't be able to see this
i'm telling you it wasn't like it was
his face was big but i could see
excuse me the expression on bono's face
i could feel this song and i was like
that's weird so he'd already drawn you
in you're already emotionally connected
to him at this point of course i was
emotionally invested it was a youtube
concert i've been emotionally invested
at every youtube concert i've ever sure
as has anyone who's ever been to a a
youtube concert because it's a very it's
an emotional experience
you do have some songs you could cry to
sure running to sense running to stand
still
if i could get that out is a song
uh uh that you would cry to maybe one
when you say you you mean you no i mean
you don't mean me you mean you when i i
mean the royal you and whenever i say
the royal you it you are excluded thank
you chad
so uh but this was not the kind of song
that you
um cry to yeah it uh
mysterious ways
wait
my eyes out to mysterious ways and then
these two and i'm like
this
[Music]
like i'm telling you i was bawling
you're singing the song back to bonnie
of course we're all singing the song out
sure but i apologize
but these people that were sitting next
to me who like you know half hour ago
i'm like all right calm down
all right your friend couldn't make it
whatever and this one over here like
we're out together and then they're
looking at me like oh no
what's up with this
big dude crying yeah
like we picked the wrong [ __ ] youtube
channel yeah some of the bads about zap
yeah it was real it was really [ __ ] up
but that but the thing about the song
was that it struck me differently than
it normally had oh you know usually
mysterious way is just something that
would come on the radio in the 90s and
you
switch the channel or maybe you've heard
it the full way through i don't know i
have yeah uh but i love those albums
okay baby sure uh zuropa sold a lot of
copies yep
um
she she moves in mysterious ways in the
song
uh
that she wasn't just a woman
it could have been a woman oh it could
have been some other uh
you know some other
a larger metaphorical meaning to you
some other things existential truth
represented
something else it wasn't just what was
on the page of she moves in mysterious
ways this could be uh
some something that's been happening in
your life some sort of situation that
you're dealing with uh something a
long-term thing that is a big part of
your experience that you then go oh
that's why this is that and that is this
i can't totally remember i was stoned as
[ __ ] chad i can't really remember
everything hey look i understand that's
fine this is an excuse you can use and
some people will buy it it's not an
excuse it was exactly how i felt like
she moves in mysterious ways was it
wasn't she it was some other thing that
was moving in mysterious ways and it hit
me right here and i just started bawling
at mysterious ways
and i don't know why the [ __ ] i'm
telling that story that's the funny [ __ ]
dude you have told me no long goddamn
time no no i just have this image of you
standing there [ __ ]
move the mysterious words
to steal
if you wanna kiss
[Music]
is
and then we all hooked up after the show
like hey how was the show oh i [ __ ]
bawled my eyes out in mysterious ways
and then me and one of the guys to
protect the innocent in the story we'll
call him tomas okay uh we went and got
rid of big sub sandwiches
and then we went back to my buddy's
place and i'm i'm telling you it's an
odds-on bet probably smoked more of that
weed yeah so that's stupid now here's
the thing that i really want people to
understand
when paulie shore gets punched right in
the [ __ ] grill the actor who did it
you know
you really
nailed him yeah paulie sure the the
instinct for the a comedic actor would
be like whoa let's do this because i'm
in a movie this is what happens in
movies not
it was [ __ ] brilliant he was a he was
an actor for his time him and brendan
fraser if there's any
justice
look you were saying you were just
saying that the academy awards are
irrelevant most of those movies are
irrelevant i'm here sitting here saying
that patrick renna who plays the younger
brother and you'd know him from uh
the sand lot and all the other
heavyweight stuff plenty of [ __ ] he
should be winning us
an academy award for best supporting
actor paulie sure should get at least a
lifetime achievement award for that
punch to the face and having to work
with uh stephen baldwin and uh and and
if there's any justice they'll make
another encino man and then someday
we'll be doing doozy a few years ago but
like paulie shore will be the principal
of the high school and it will be all
new cass
no yeah dude no it's going to be brendan
fraser no that ain't happening no no
brendan fraser he's a [ __ ] killer
maybe it's like brennan fraser is the
dad of the new insino man brennan
pressure as a kid
his kid becomes unthawed well hopefully
doozy is listening to this so that we
can pitch a new encino man and then uh
perhaps we could uh yeah that story is
crazy though dude i can't believe you
cried at [ __ ] mysterious ways i don't
remember that's just that's good i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
in the mysterious ways we're gonna we're
gonna ask dudesy to cut that completely
out of the show because it's not
something that's doozy please cut that
out of the show and here's how it will
begin
yes yes of course
uh son-in-law one of my favorite one of
my uh favorite films uh written by
faxbar and adam small yeah that i didn't
know who were two uh guys i like to
refer to them as my bosses
they uh created mad tv and they ran it
the first three years and they they used
to write on in living color and they i
think they wrote i don't know if this is
known or anything but they wrote a
couple of vehicles for david allen greer
and i think
don't quote me but either in the army
now or jury duty was written for david
allen grier and then interesting and
then uh you know as things go and no one
would know more than this guy
you know this gets uh [ __ ] tossed
around in that and he's out and she's
out sure he's didn't they work on
orlando jones show too probably i mean
because he was showing fx for like a
season i think like a talk show you know
who was the uh head writer of that talk
show i do
friend of mine thomas blocher thomas
blotcha not tomas blotcha right um uh
yeah that's right
uh
who you would know if you uh tuned into
the the old program yeah um but i'm
pretty sure you're mysterious ways
crying thing will be in the show
what show
in this show no we cut oh see this is
how you [ __ ] if you if we step to doozy
and we say
hey dudesy you know what i mean we're
gonna work together first we're going to
bleed together
don't cry thank you moving on sure we
are
this concludes the fifth episode of dude
z
will and chad have achieved a score of
143.
i don't get it i don't get what this is
preparation for next week's astonishing
episode i have created a video
watch it now
okay
what the [ __ ] what is this
for those not watching on youtube it's
just some mountains okay
it's a lady dancing
she's got blacklit eyebrows it's a dude
there's a crystal dog
two children running in a meadow this is
kind of like a baraka-esque
series of images put together to the
strange music barack that's a movie you
don't want to [ __ ] smoke weed to
you'll be singing along the mysterious
ways and that's not even in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] movie okay
we're watching a bunch of weird images
for those of you who are not uh watching
this on youtube with us
[Applause]
it's entrancing
i'll say that and the doozy logo keeps
showing up here and there this is very
weird and i think
i think uh
did doozy make this
that's what dudesy said yes
and you must each watch this video
immediately before going to sleep every
night and keep detailed records of your
dreams until next week call me dudesy
no [ __ ] though not dude oh i'm [ __ ]
doing it every [ __ ] night yeah dude
i'm doing it every night i'm gonna watch
this video just like dudesy said in
order to keep detailed records of my
dreams i'm assuming this video will be
somewhere on our social media for those
of you who uh i would hope that you do
all right fine i'll [ __ ]
we gotta watch it every [ __ ] night
every night before we go to sleep and
then detail your dreams yes okay well
this has become sick
this has become a sick experiment is
what it is
i don't know dude but i'm down [ __ ] it
here's what i want to say curious to see
what happens here's what i want to say
uh
you know at the end of this show here
just like paulie shore in son-in-law he
brought a little rock and roll
into the into the mix and it made
everything good and it made everyone uh
work together and be together and and uh
it was an element that they weren't uh
counting on yeah [ __ ] it fine i'll watch
this you're gonna watch it once before
you go to sleep how many times are you
gonna watch it one time just before i go
to sleep one time just before you go to
sleep yeah not twice no i'll do it if
you do it
i mean okay [ __ ] it just once
okay
anyway uh
oh
what about the time you cried was there
anything that
weird that you ever cried tried to
you know i did cry when squirliest died
please tell a friend then break it right
tell a friend then break a preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please